one of the things that i've realized is
that
people that are self-reflective
that rely on cerebral horsepower
that pay attention that think in a
detailed way
the more nuance that you're thinking is
the fewer people are going to be like
you which makes you feel more alone
how do you think people can overcome
this
well i would say that hasn't been my
experience exactly
because
as i started to make my thoughts more
public
they seem to appeal to more and more
people
and so i don't know if that's a
threshold phenomena because maybe it is
you know
as you start to become specialized as a
scientist
in some sense your vision narrows and
narrows
although it gets more high resolution at
the level that you're operating but you
kind of pass through a
needle let's say
out the other side where the thing
you're studying starts to become
everything again
and so maybe that's maybe that's that
developmental progression further more
yeah specialization and then
generalization again yeah yeah i think
that you might be right there the deeper
into the breach thing the show that i
went to go and see you do in manchester
in 2017 or 18. someone asked a question
about um the depth of my consciousness
causes me to suffer and you said you
take more of the thing that poisons you
until you turn it into a tonic that
girdles the world around you and i think
that this is something you see here as
well that when you start to think
differently when you start to consider
the way that you're living your life in
a
more detailed higher resolution
more unique more nuanced way you will
probably receive pushback especially you
know speaking from personal experience
in a normal working class towns people
born live die in these places
it's insular
there isn't a huge
culture of especially in the uk tall
poppy syndrome is a huge problem the
biggest difference that i've noticed
actually between
american people and english people
is that american children are told that
they can be anything that they want to
be
[Music]
they're told that they have blue sky
vision they can achieve whatever they
want and that gives them a lot of
confidence
when us brits stuffy stiffer brits see
americans on tv it sounds like
everyone's had media training because
everybody's just so enthused about
whatever it is even if it's a 18-car
pileup
and then the
equivalent in the uk is that
deviating from the norm is very very
very
quickly mocked
and there's a lot of that in canada too
tall puppy syndrome it's a big deal
now
the japanese have that saying too except
it's um
the nail that sticks up above all the
rest is the first one to be struck down
by the hammer
and there's some truth in that too
there's some truth in that but
some
and all are very different words
when you roll the clock forward what you
end up with
is american children that then become
adults who
look around at the world and say well
hang on this wasn't what i was promised
i was told that i could be anything that
i wanted to be i was told that i could
have anything that i wanted to there's a
difference between you can earn
everything that is earnable and you
deserve everything there is
so that message can become
what you say it can become
misinterpreted in a narcissistic manner
and i think that has happened to some
degree especially as people have had
fewer and fewer children
you know
jonathan height and luke enough talk
about the coddling of the american mind
and they think about that in large part
as a consequence of
an ideological transformation
and some of that's true but it's
also useful to look at more fundamental
phenomena
people have children when they're a lot
older
they have way fewer children they have
way more resources when they have
children on average you know if you're
one kid of eight you're pretty much
battling it out for attention for a very
finite amount of parental attention with
a lot of intense competition and the
probability that you're going to come
out of that entitled and narcissistic is
pretty damn low because your siblings
will definitely punish you for that but
if you're the only child especially of
older parents who are also more
conservative because of their age and
also less willing to take chances with
you because there's only one of you and
then you have a lot of resources at your
disposal well that's a whole different
that's a whole different
developmental milieu and we have no idea
what the consequences of that are but
the idea that children in that
circumstance are more likely to be
overprotected and dependent and
structured it's like well yeah
undoubtedly
and you know that that would even be an
overabundance of parental virtue in some
sense right
well we just did nothing but pay
attention to our child
okay but
too much what did you expect it's so
strange because i'm an only child right
and all of the well maybe my friends
might say differently
but a lot of the commonly held
presumptions around only children
i just and i have a couple of friends
who are as well and i don't know whether
it's where we're from that the northeast
of the uk is very spit and sawdust it's
salt of the earth people it's you know
grab your boots straps on your boots and
start pulling and
i just haven't i haven't seen that what
what is it
through your clinical practice what the
hell might not be a
primarily working class phenomena you
know that the coddled mind phenomena
that could easily be a middle class and
upper phenomena is there something is
was there a common trend or from your
reading have you found that only
children
tend to be one way or another no
no i just get huge variants in them as
well i don't know the answer to that at
the level of individual psychological
data there might be a literature i'm not
aware of it that for me that was more
response to heights book on the caudal
mind i thought okay
fair enough coddling of the american
mind what's driving this
it's not just ideas it's a huge
demographic switch it's a huge
transformation in the way we raise
children we're 10 years older when we
have our children now that's a lot older
you know when you're 18 you have a kid
you're still a kid and that there's some
wildness that's perhaps not so good
about that but there's also perhaps
a higher proclivity to go off and live
your own life
and then you know the how much children
how much should your children be left on
their own
the answer is as much as they can
tolerate
and how much is that well
you find out with each child
but it's certainly possible to not
deprive your child enough what's
happening people if you enjoyed that
then press here for the full unedited
episode and don't forget to subscribe
peace
oh